[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hablamos de espionaje es seguro
seguro que se te vienen a la mente
escenas de películas protagonizadas por
son con él y roger moore o pierce
brosnan quien nos recuerda acaso el
clásico aston martin del agente 007
windscreen
sin embargo amigos por fortuna o por
desgracia lo cierto es que espionaje en
el mundo real tiene poco que ver con la
vida lo que clamorosa de james bond
aunque claro quién en su sano juicio
iría a ver una película en la que pierce
brosnan se pasara 120 minutos escuchando
llamadas telefónicas o recolectando
metadatos
y es que desde la antigua roma hasta
nuestros días es ha sido básicamente la
misión de los servicios de inteligencia
saber qué se dice y quién lo dice
[Música]
puede que julio césar no tuviera
potentes equipos informáticos o
satélites a su disposición pero se libró
varias veces de la muerte gracias
precisamente a tener una poderosa red de
informantes a su servicio de hecho se
dice incluso que podría haber sido
conocedor de la conspiración que
finalmente acabó con su vida
[Música]
otro ejemplo la revolución francesa de
robespierre y compañía muy probablemente
tampoco habría sido posible sin su red
de inteligencia no al menos tal y como
se produjo el gobierno revolucionario
contaba con comités de inteligencia
repartidos por todo el país que se
dedicaban a identificar monitorizar y
arrestar a todo noble extranjero o
francés vuelto del exterior que pudiera
ir en contra del movimiento para que os
hagáis una idea algunos historiadores
llegan a cifrar en casi medio millón el
número de personas vigiladas por esta
inmensa red
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero del siglo 18 saltemos hasta el 2013
ese año una filtración de un consultor
tecnológico un hasta entonces
desconocido edward snowden hizo temblar
todos los resortes del poder en
washington
amigos a través de periodistas del
washington post y the gardian el
empleado de la n sea filtró documentos
clasificados como alto secreto que
revelaban la existencia de varios
programas de inteligencia programas que
recolectaban metadatos de ciudadanos
norteamericanos de forma masiva
pero en qué consistían exactamente estos
programas que es realmente la n sea qué
papel jugó el 11-s en términos de
privacidad pues atentos porque en este
vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas
la agencia secreta
el 20 de mayo de 1949 el entonces
secretario de defensa de los eeuu luís
johnson creó en la a efe s/a la agencia
de seguridad de las fuerzas armadas su
propósito era el de coordinar todas las
comunicaciones electrónicas y trabajos
de inteligencia de las diferentes
agencias pertenecientes a las fuerzas
armadas agenciadas como por ejemplo el
servicio de seguridad de las fuerzas
aéreas o el grupo de seguridad de la
marina
[Música]
sin embargo amigos un rotundo fracaso la
rivalidad entre las diferentes agencias
era tan grande que al final nunca
compartían toda la información con esta
especie de órgano central
precisamente por este motivo en junio
del 52 y dado que la app sa había
terminado siendo totalmente inoperativa
e incapaz de responder a las necesidades
que planteaba la nueva 'guerra fría' el
presidente truman decidió dar un golpe
en la mesa y montará algo completamente
nuevo de esta forma autorizó la creación
de una nueva agencia secreta lo hizo a
través de un memorándum confidencial
concretamente al final de la séptima
página de este fueron unas breves líneas
que cambiarían la historia del espionaje
en norteamérica para siempre
os imaginais a truman dictando el
documento a su secretaria
después de seis páginas de repente oye
sí mira también lo de que vamos a crear
una mega agencia de inteligencia pero
que no se entere nadie ni siquiera el
congreso sobre todo el congreso
[Música]
amigos así es como nació la n aunque no
sería esta más de 20 años después cuando
se supo públicamente que esta agencia
existía de hecho se supo gracias a las
investigaciones llevadas a cabo en 1975
por el senador sobre los posibles abusos
de los servicios de inteligencia
norteamericanos
fue entonces cuando el comité church
desveló que existe una agencia con un
presupuesto milmillonario una agencia de
la que nadie había oído hablar y es que
ni siquiera los propios senadores daban
crédito a la envergadura que la enee se
había alcanzado
a diferencia de la cia que fue creada a
través del congreso la ms había sido
puesta en marcha directamente por el
poder ejecutivo es decir por el gobierno
de los eeuu durante décadas la
casablanca llevó a cabo un minucioso
trabajo que la hizo pasar completamente
desapercibida mientras la organización
no paraba de crecer y crecer
si parece que aquí los contrapesos los
famosos check and balance llegaron 23
años tarde el caso amigos es que el
congreso no daba crédito acababan de
descubrir que la n sea una organización
prácticamente desconocida no sólo una
agencia más grande que la mismísima cia
sino que de hecho era más grande que el
resto de agencia de inteligencia juntas
para que os hagáis una idea de su tamaño
el último dato que se conoce es que en
1978 y a pesar de los recortes que trajo
consigo el fin de la guerra de vietnam
la plantilla de la cne se ascendía ni
más ni menos que a 68 mil 203 empleados
esto es más del doble que todos los
trabajadores que tienen carrefour en
españa' o más de la mitad de los
empleados de apple en todo el mundo todo
en el más absoluto de los secretos a
pesar de su tamaño y poder nunca se ha
promulgado ninguna ley que prohíba la ns
a participar en ninguna actividad solo
hay leyes que prohíben la divulgación de
cualquier información sobre la agencia
ningún estatuto establece la enee sea ni
define el alcance permisible de sus
responsabilidades frank church ex
presidente del comité de inteligencia
del senado y amigos si esto es parecía
sorprendente esperad un momento porque
la historia no ha terminado aquí
[Aplausos]
el senado también descubrió que la n seã
se había dedicado a pinchar las
conversaciones de casi 1700
norteamericanos incluso en 1969 la
administración nixon le llegó a poner
nombre a esta particular lista de
personas a vigilar sería la conocida
como 'operación minarete todo un
escándalo personajes tan destacados como
martin luther king james fonda o mohamed
alí formaron parte de esta curiosa lista
negra de la iglesia
[Música]
de hecho la paranoia de la
administración nixon fue tal que incluso
se dedicaron a espiar a su propia gente
por ejemplo el conocido senador
republicano por tennessee dijo ward
baker que llegó a ser líder de la
mayoría y mencionado y más tarde incluso
jefe de gabinete del presidente ronald
reagan también formó parte de la lista
de sospechosos a ojos de la iglesia
el caso es que en ese mismo año de 1978
y probablemente como consecuencia de
haber descubierto las opacas y
controvertidas andanzas de la enee sea
el congreso aprobó la conocida como fish
a la ford en intelligent surveillance a
la fisa puso legalmente frenos a la
barra libre de escuchas que hasta ese
momento tuvo la enee sea a partir de la
aprobación de esta ley la n sea sólo
podía interceptar es decir pinchar
comunicaciones que tuvieran lugar en el
extranjero prohibiendo expresamente la
vigilancia a ciudadanos estadounidenses
salvo en el caso de aquellos que
actuasen como espías de otros países
[Música]
desde la aprobación de la pizza para
poder iniciar el monitoreo del ciudadano
la iglesia necesita obtener una orden
judicial lo que nos parece sensato no
creéis
[Música]
pues amigos un momento porque un
acontecimiento que cambiaría por
completo los límites de esta agencia
créeme
live
el día que lo cambió todo
hay una fecha en el calendario que
marcaría un antes y un después para la
agencia de seguridad nacional de los
eeuu el 11 de septiembre del 2001
casi dos décadas después de ese fatídico
día podemos decir casi con toda
seguridad que el 11 de septiembre ha
sido la operación terrorista que más
consecuencias ha desencadenado en toda
la historia de la humanidad ese día
desaparecieron de la faz de la tierra 19
finalistas tres mil vidas inocentes un
emblema como las torres gemelas y cuatro
aviones de pasajeros pero no sólo eso
fue mucho lo que no se destruyó pero sí
quedó dañado en algunos casos para
siempre miles de heridos un edificio
estratégico como el pentágono y un país
que nunca volvería a ser el mismo
amigos el 11 se trastocó de lleno la
agenda política de la administración
bush y no sólo hablamos de las guerras
de afganistán e irak
[Música]
lo cierto es que el congreso
prácticamente le dirá el entonces
presidente bush un cheque en blanco para
poder utilizar a las fuerzas armadas de
la forma que considerara necesaria para
perseguir y castigar a todo aquel que
hubiera estado implicado en los
atentados y eso no fue todo un mes
después del 11-s el congreso aprobó la
patriot act una ley que daba la potestad
a los cuerpos de seguridad para poder
luchar contra el terrorismo con las
mismas tácticas que podían emplear para
luchar contra el crimen organizado o el
narcotráfico por ejemplo gracias a la
patriot act los agentes podían conseguir
acceso a las llamadas los planes de
viaje o cualquier otra información
disponible en otras agencias federales
de un sospechoso de terrorismo
en one ford f100 por minutos
fire presentan
y aún más si el 11-s había supuesto una
bofetada para alguien ese alguien fueron
sin duda las agencias de inteligencia
y la respuesta fue clara hacía falta más
mucha más inteligencia de esta forma y
tal y como años más tarde se supo en el
2002 el presidente bush firmó una orden
secreta presidencial una orden que
permitía la n sea monitorizar las
llamadas y los correos electrónicos de
miles de ciudadanos y residentes legales
en los eeuu sin necesidad ojo sin
necesidad de tener que solicitar una
orden judicial fue el nacimiento del
programa estelar wind
pero la guinda la guinda amigos llegó en
el 2005 con la designación de un nuevo
director para la ms a un hombre que
supuso un punto y aparte de la historia
de la iglesia y por extensión en la
historia del espionaje atentos
e
y un cowboy en washington
el 1 de agosto del 2005 el general keith
alexander fue designado como el
decimosexto director de la n seã
sirviendo en el cargo durante nueve años
ningún director de la agencia ha servido
nunca tanto tiempo y desde luego ningún
director tuvo antes tanto poder en sus
manos la ambición de este personaje
simplemente no tenía precedentes
alexander te envía a actuar a veces como
un cowboy decía nos preocupemos por la
ley vamos a descubrir cómo hacer el
trabajo un ex funcionario de
inteligencia llegó a decirnos que muchas
cosas no eran claramente legales pero
que eso no las hacía ilegales ex oficial
de inteligencia militar que sirvió bajo
alexander en el inss como aparentemente
alexander parecía el tipo perfecto para
el puesto
se trataba de todo un alto oficial de
inteligencia condecorado graduado en
west point y especializado en física y
tecnología por ejemplo durante la guerra
de irak fue pionero utilizando
herramientas para monitorizar todas las
comunicaciones llamadas correos y
mensajes que se producían en irak ojo el
tiempo real
sin embargo el anterior director de la
iglesia del general michael hayden no
quería ver alexander ni en pintura claro
que amigos alexander contaban no con uno
sino con dos ases en la manga para
hacerse con la silla primero sabía que
hayden se iba a matar con el entonces
secretario de defensa donald rumsfeld
por eso se puso como primer objetivo
meterse a rafael en el bolsillo
y segundo se sabía mover por washington
como pez en el agua
digamos que sabía cómo encandilar a la
gente que necesitaba para lograr todas
sus metas congresistas senadores
asesores de la casa blanca el general
alexander iba a por todas
[Música]
eloy general de cuatro estrellas dirigía
entonces un comando de inteligencia en
virginia cerca de washington pues bien
para que os hagáis una idea del tipo de
persona de la que estamos hablando en
esas instalaciones montó un decorado
propio del mismísimo hollywood
concretamente una réplica del puesto de
mando de la nave enterprise de la famosa
serie star trek
pero vale vale puede que os estáis
preguntando y para qué demonios quería
semejante cosa pues digamos que desde
ese puesto de mando controlaba las
pantallas y los ordenadores de su
conocido como centro de dominios de
información y no sólo eso de esta forma
cada vez que invitaba a un político le
hacía un tour donde terminaba sentando a
su invitado el asiento del capitán del
inter price y sabéis que los políticos
flipaban que hayan rendido les encantaba
si amigos resulta difícil de creer pero
con técnicas como esta es como el
general alexander consiguió meterse a
todos en el bolsillo y si así es también
como llegó a convertirse en el director
de la poderosa en s a
pero bien no nos desviemos el caso es
que durante el largo mandato de
alexander uno de sus objetivos
principales fue renovar tecnológicamente
la agencia quizás uno de los personajes
que mejor ilustran los cambios que se
produjeron en esta organización fue
eduard snowden
y esque economics under al frente y la
agencia se llenó de jóvenes fichajes de
la noche a la mañana 20 los imberbes
andaban por las instalaciones de la
iglesia con niveles de acceso que ni
siquiera los agentes más veteranos
habían conseguido nunca amigos la era
digital había llegado lleva décadas más
joven que los tipos del centro de apoyo
y pasaba por delante de ellos hacia la
cámara acorazada a la que ellos nunca
habían accedido ni accederían nunca
edward snowden con sus nuevos fichajes
denominada la renovada universidad de
alexander empezó a llevar a cabo nuevos
programas de espionaje uno de los más
controvertidos fue el programa prisma
con el la enee se ha comenzó a almacenar
información de internet y de compañías
tecnológicas emails vídeo chats mensajes
de redes sociales todo quedaba al
alcance de los analistas de la agencia
para buscar pistas sobre nuevas amenazas
terroristas
de hecho fue tanta la información
almacenada por esta agencia y en la n se
quedó sin capacidad de almacenamiento en
sus 141 hectáreas de la base de fort me
tuvieron que ampliar su disco duro o
montando unas instalaciones en mitad del
desierto de utah que les costó más de
dos mil millones de dólares
pero sabéis a cuánta gente se calcula
que llego a monitorizar la n sea con
este programa a cuántos sospechosos del
terrorismo pues estima que la cantidad
podría ascender a varias decenas de
millones de estadounidenses si lo habéis
escuchado bien decenas y decenas de
millones de estadounidenses un momento
que como justificaba la universidad
legalmente el monitoreo de tanta gente
pues veréis como dice el dicho hecha la
ley hecha la trampa
cris english el subdirector de la
agencia declaró en el congreso que
cuando se tenía un posible terrorista en
vigilancia se investigaban las
comunicaciones de personas relacionadas
con este hasta un tercer grado de
conexión
y claro vamos a ver si tenemos en cuenta
que hace poco un estudio de la
universidad de milán junto a facebook
estimó que en la actualidad todos
estamos conectados en aproximadamente 47
grados de separación entonces los tres
grados que utilizaba la iglesia no se
parece excesivo no cree una tomadura de
pelo porque de esta forma tenían en la
práctica vía libre para investigar aquí
les diera la gana el general alexander
nos enseñaban montones de diagramas que
relacionaban a un tipo conectado con
otro tipo a ese con otro a su vez
oficial de la enee sea que atendió
briefings de kif al examen mis
compañeros y yo no nos lo creíamos más
tarde tuvimos la oportunidad de revisar
la información pues resulta que la
conexión que tenían todos esos tipos era
que compraban en la misma pizzeria
oficial militar retirado que trabajó con
alexander el caso es que todo esto a la
iglesia se le fue mucho pero que mucho
de las manos filtraciones de documentos
revelaron que tan sólo el españa y
francia llegaron a interceptar más de 10
millones de llamadas telefónicas y bueno
puede que muchos recordéis este
bochornoso momento de la administración
obama barack obama aprobó pinchar el
teléfono de angela merkel hace tres años
el presidente barack obama fue informado
sobre el monitoreo la canciller alemana
en 2010 y permitió que continuara el
teléfono de merkel los correos del
entonces presidente de mexico felipe
calderon y otros 35 jefes de estado más
[Música]
la barra libre de las escuchas era tal
que el propio snowden llegó a reconocer
que había empleado de la necesidad que
se dedicaban a espiar a sus novias a sus
ex parejas oa quien quisieran con la más
absoluta impunidad
[Música]
a pesar de todo y tras haberse gastado
miles y miles de millones de dólares en
estos programas la propia n se anunció a
principios de 2019 la suspensión del
programa por el cual las operadoras
telefónicas tenían que pasarle los
registros de sus clientes según la
propia agencia los beneficios habían
sido bastante pequeños comparados con el
coste y los recursos empleados parece
que utilizar semejante cantidad de datos
en la práctica no resultaba nada fácil
vamos que a la hora de la verdad el
programa fue utilizado más para espiar
las novias de los empleados de la
agencia y cosas por el estilo que para
luchar contra el terrorismo y bueno
también para espiar a líderes políticos
como merkel claro que estamos seguros de
que eso ya no se hace en cualquier caso
no era el objetivo por el que se acordó
violar la privacidad de millones y
millones de personas de todo el mundo y
por el que se gastaron miles y miles de
millones de dólares
[Música]
en fin amigos esta es la historia de una
de las agencias de inteligencia más
desconocidas del mundo una agencia que
durante más de 20 años fue de facto
ocultaba hasta el propio congreso de los
eeuu una agencia que las actividades
diarias desconocemos pero que sabemos
fue capaz de violar sin ningún escrúpulo
la privacidad de millones y millones de
ciudadanos inocentes por supuesto entre
ellos empresarios políticos y
periodistas y eso debe hacer que nos
formulamos algunas preguntas crees que
es conveniente que un órgano dependiente
de un gobierno tenga semejante grado de
libertad para actuar está 10 dispuesto a
sacrificar toda tu privacidad para
supuestamente fortalecer la seguridad
nacional que control crees que tendrían
que tener este tipo de agencias déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios muy
pronto aquí en visual político os
contaremos muchos más detalles sobre
este mundo así que ya sabes no olvides
suscribirte al canal si aún no lo has
hecho y por supuesto si este vídeo te
resulta interesante no olvides darle al
botón de like una vez más muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]